hi I'm Helene Gayle president and CEO of
care care is an international
humanitarian and development
organization working globally in over 80
countries around the world we're in 16
countries here in Asia and one of the
areas of particular focus for us is
empowering girls and women because we
believe that if you can empower girls
and women you can have an impact on
changing families and societies the role
of women here in Asia is very important
we talked about this many in many
different forums in the World Economic
Forum here in Asia because the
importance of women for economic growth
for political power and improved
governance and for peace and security we
know that women play such an important
role in all of those arenas and here in
Asia it's very important that women be
included in the equation and it's
important force for moving countries
forward here in this region as well as
around the world